[Applause]
[Music]
hey
welcome
to batman beyond i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernardin hey
kids hello how are you man
uh it's time uh again my friends
uh to kick back and and just
submerge ourselves in the pa and the
culture that pops ladies and gentlemen
um talk about those things
that we love
some of us don't like uh we'll see uh
talk about
all the news all the things to look
forward to
that are coming out that's what we do
here on
fat man beyond in case you needed to
recap and i don't think anybody did
um how are you captain i'm good man i'm
good i'm uh you know busy as ever and
busy is good
um what is your uh
in code
which project are you working on
uh let's see
yours theirs
i'm working on two
things that are theirs
two things that are mine one of which is
a comic book
um
and then
prepping
to pitch a third thing that is mine
um
so yeah so there's there's five balls in
the air
you busy man i got a pitch in the
morning i yeah
it'd be a cool show if it goes but i've
i've you know
you know the longer one is in this
business
the more one
holds back enthusiasm
until one sees
you know some sort of certainty uh you
gotta understand you go on the pitch and
odds are they're not gonna say yes
so
it's a weird tightrope
that one has to walk because you got to
go in there all piss and vinegar and
passion like i want to make this [ __ ]
thing
but you can't
truly let yourself live in that place
because when they're like well we don't
want to make that [ __ ] thing
you're not jj you dumbass in the hat get
out of here
then you gotta [ __ ] deal with like
well how am i gonna how am i supposed to
live without you get all laura bran
again about it
um so it's a weird balance man i there's
a i look forward to the thing we're
pitching tomorrow but like at the same
time
you know
so many hurdles
to
it ever becoming a reality so yeah this
is the first round and yeah see and it
can still it can it can lead you down
that road for years
of like optimism and hope and joy and
then the rug can get pulled
it's like but wait a minute like you
bought the thing you even paid me money
and then i wrote a thing and we were
like starting to cast a thing and then
it goes away like you're talking to
captain kingdom keepers over here
[Laughter]
you know i just i was deep diving into
one of my old laptops looking for
uh
an old photo and i found
a script to plastic man
that i wrote for a plastic man cartoon
like two years ago or something like
that i completely [ __ ]
forgot about it and they paid me to
write it and then they didn't do it and
it was with um what's his name from the
big bang theory
um lovely guy
oh
yeah the guy younger
right old sheldon old show yeah
um
him with him he was such a good dude who
is now why is his name did i smoke his
name away
um come on chat yeah i don't i don't
think i've ever known his i i knew of
him clearly but i never watched big bang
it was not my thing he's like one of the
most famous people in the world man uh
jim parsons thank you
the
the app eyes
good looking out uh jim parsons man what
a lovely dude but uh he was gonna be the
voice of plastic men
um so i i looked at the script and i was
like wow man they [ __ ] paid me to
write this and it's never gonna happen
like
it happens all the time like you know
who
brian lynch one of the most talented
people that i know
he's a great writer like you like a
zillion [ __ ] great ideas a minute
um you know for he's been doing like uh
he worked for illumination for like a
decade or whatever he did minions and he
did
hop i think hop was his first one he did
a bunch of movies with those cats puss
and boots and [ __ ]
but like for [ __ ] 10 years prior to
him making a single one of those movies
that [ __ ] made such a healthy
living writing amazing scripts that
nobody's ever seen
like it got bought
like you know and i was i would always
be like i was so jealous of you man like
you come up with like you just [ __ ]
crap great ideas
and then you you could get paid like
handsomely to write scripts and they
don't even make the script so you never
have to worry about whether you were
right or not
but you know he was just like it sucks
writing a bunch of things that don't get
made you know he's like
so and so then he then he hit [ __ ]
pay dirt with illumination then they
were making everything that he wrote um
so it's weird it's a weird dance
when one had to go in and pitch and and
like for example i finished uh this is
not about pitching but
talk about pulling the taffy and keeping
the passion alive for a project that can
go on for [ __ ] years
i just finished a script today for a
project that i started
eons ago i gotta be
let me see
pre jane zombob reboot roadshow tour
so you know 2019 so like three years ago
and you know so many times i was like
this thing ain't gonna happen and then
it [ __ ] happened and now like
everything's in an accelerated
stage we haven't announced what it is
yet so i'm just i'm not being coy it's
not mine to announce right somebody
somebody is like hey we gave you a lot
of money can we [ __ ] announce it and
i'm like fine
um
yes it's like a few months yeah i mean i
got a podcast but sure you go do it yeah
i was like look i don't know if you know
this or not but i do a show called fat
man beyond you want me to lie to my
audience
um but uh yeah it's
it's crazy how long that [ __ ]
took but and then that's like
at least it's taking
yeah
think about all the [ __ ] that never
[ __ ] takes or never goes anyplace man
ooh it's
it's crazy it's such a weird
lottery of a business man it all comes
down to taste right it comes down to
like whoever's in that room
it's not like netflix where it's like
they got an algorithm and they're like
oh [ __ ] you know if it's got these
[ __ ] four elements you're in
but like it's you know it's
it's comes down to whoever's sitting
there that you're like all right imagine
it's this and we're doing this and it
comes down to that
person's
taste
as to whether or not the world sees that
tv show that movie blah blah blah yeah
you know and also some of it is personal
taste some of it is i know what my
bosses will like
you know it could be
it's the weirdest experience going into
a room and pitching somebody who seems
to deadpan you the whole way through
because what you want is like some
feedback you want some genuine
enthusiasm on the other side
and that person could not like what you
pitched but know that his boss will
you know and so you can walk out of that
room feeling like yeah crap the bed it's
never going to go and then you get the
call it's like yeah they bought it like
wait what
that guy bought it he hated it i could
tell he looked hateful
had that exact story happen to me once
it was like if we pitched
buckaroo banzai
with mgm
this is going back a few years
um a few different places
and the last place we pitched it
like i really thought the executive was
like just
thought i was a douche
because the dude was like kind of like
you know he's like how's your day and i
was like you know just been pitching
everywhere and whatnot
i said it would be you'd make my day a
lot better if you guys would buy it
and he was like all right we're buying
it
yeah all right great
and then i pitched but it felt like he
was being like sarcastic so like i gave
a half-hearted pitch and [ __ ]
and then i like uh we left and you know
i had to go to uh
[ __ ] oil change place and while i was
there i called my agent i was like hey
man don't please don't ever send me to
that [ __ ] place again like that was
crazy insulting like nobody has to kiss
my ass but like
that that dude just [ __ ] treated me
like a dick man and he's like that dude
just bought it
and i was like what and he was like wait
he bought it he said that he told you
right at the beginning that he was gonna
buy it i was like i thought he was just
being an [ __ ]
lovely guy named morgan when he worked
that was when he worked at
i think we sold it to amazon first
and then like you know [ __ ] couple
years went by and something
didn't happen
then when i got re i jumped off of it
then i got reinvolved at a certain point
and
we went and pitched it again
and we went and pitched it to apple
and it was the same exact morgan
and i was like oh morgan you can make
history and buy it twice he's like i
will and he did
and we were set up at apple for like a
long time and i think i i don't know let
me see
the last i heard was
i mean i i guess i could talk about this
now
i mean
yeah i think it's all over
so i was attached to this you know
bunker bonsai
thing for years live action
then it morphed into an animated series
and that's what we were talking about
doing with apple
and
this is
crazy
but
um i had a zoom
i i'm trying to let me make sure i'm
just want to make sure i'm not gonna get
in trouble
yeah i'm like is there well i mean
there's no like
it's telling tales out of school but
like i think the project's dead anyway
so
i you know i guess i could tell the
story
um
i had a zoom
just like this but it was one-on-one
with neo himself
i remember
piano reeves man who was so
[ __ ] sweet
such a nice guy
like just [ __ ] lovely and he was like
um he's going so buckaroo banzai
he was going like i'm like i just think
it would be fun like it was crazy and
and
he was
he was in for like a half a minute
for playing our buckaroo banza the voice
of our baku banzai and the animate
series he like he's like i love
animation i love comic books he's gone
and i've always loved buckaroo banzai
says like this is he and he you know he
told me he loved me
this is a no-brainer and i was like oh
my god
i couldn't believe it and stuff and then
uh he
jumped out he sent me a note and he was
just like it was great to talk to you
unfortunately i can't do buckaroo banzai
based on something else or whatever
lovely dude to even like send me a
[ __ ]
like oops i was wrong or whatever
which uh
but but you know that project went on
for a long time and i swore at that
point i was like
oh my god
if we if if if we've got [ __ ] neil
playing the voice of bakura banzai
this is gonna happen and it didn't
happen it didn't happen
well there's always round three
where morgan after i tell that story
they're like you're [ __ ] fired dude
and plus the third time's a charm was
like somebody else i'm sure they're like
once bitten twice shy you know
and i had like one
well find out where morgan is working
now
this is my lucky charm that's i should
just literally go pitch to him all the
time it's like hey you're a panda plus
huh
that's what i got when we first got to
apple i mean now that like we're telling
tales we first got to apple it was a
live action [ __ ] bonsai and it was
like way international where they're
like we're gonna have you shoot in japan
we're gonna have you shoot here we're
gonna be shooting here
they were like you know i was like well
the banzai institute is in new jersey to
like kind of be in
japan and i was like
yeah of course it could yeah
at the very least absolutely
do they make hummus in japan
well i don't believe me i'd be bringing
the hummus i think they don't have in
japan though is weed i think you get
[ __ ] out of trouble for weeds so
[Music]
so
no go for me that's a deal that that's
what killed it like listen guys yeah
he's like you know what
piano or not
i say keanu because i got to replace
that desmond
um so wild in any event
uh this show
um let me you know what before we dive
into the uh you know uh the
advertisement of it all who's sponsored
you know what maybe we'll do that first
and then we'll go into what i want to
talk about all right because it's long
it'll be probably a longer conversation
uh this year's show
kids uh is made possible by a grant from
the helena rubinstein foundation
and by members like you and the letter q
um this show is not helena rubinstein
i'm sure she was a wonderful woman and
stuff but she takes care of or used to
take care of public broadcasting this
ain't public broadcasting man this is
private broadcasting private
um so we we need your sponsor dollars
kids and tonight's sponsor is an old
friend of the show
um and let me tell you something
we got a lot of people in our audience
mark
yes all they want to do they got hair
they want to keeps it
they do
keeps.com ladies and gentlemen keeps
good folks at keeps
they're our sponsor tonight if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to
keeps.com k e e p s k e e
k e e p s dot com
slash fat man you're gonna receive uh
your first month of treatment free
when's that ever happened in life man
that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to get your first
month
free k-e-e-p-s dot com slash five-minute
why don't you go to their website right
now and follow along
because i guarantee you by the end of
this you're gonna be like you know what
i wanna hold on to my [ __ ] hair yeah
look at look at mark
look at we sad middle-aged gentlemen
who didn't have keeps growing up
no
we don't have a good spot
we resort to funny hats and wacky
backgrounds to distract from the fact
that we don't have a lustrous mane of
hair like [ __ ] banff man bamf man get
in here and show them what a [ __ ]
lions man hair looks like of course he's
also wearing a hat
i can
but still
there you go he ain't wearing a hat
because he's gotta he's wearing a hat by
choice because you know he didn't take a
shower or whatever the [ __ ] maybe not
that head of hair it's a guy like
[ __ ] banff man who needs keeps so
that he holds on to that hair keeps
that hair forever man like what what's
the
male pattern baldness like in your
family bath man
um
everybody nobody
was bo i think my mom's grandfather was
bald but everybody else has hair nobody
else has lost their hair like like
well jocelyn didn't have hair she was
bald that's true she was born bold
you got to get her some keeps man
keep that baby there
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35. me when i was 25 my mom was
like she watched maul rats she goes
tiger you've got a bald spot i was like
thanks ma
i wish i'd listened to her i wish there
had been keeps man because there i was
25 year old kev going what do you mean
there's a bald spot more than 50 million
men in the u.s
suffer
suffer
from male pattern baldness uh keeps has
more five-star reviews than any
of its competitors ladies and gentlemen
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both of them
mark take it away they offer a simple
affordable and stress-free way to keep
your hair via convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't even have to leave your home
24 7 care and support keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality and what does it cost what does
it cost you ask
the first month is free if you go to
eps.com fat man after that treatment
start at just ten dollars per month
ten bucks to keep your [ __ ] hair
indeed treatment plans are affordable
typically half the cost of pharmacy
prices let me tell you something
if they ever finally do invent the time
machine
i'm getting my [ __ ] ass in it
i'm going back in time and i'm just
saying one word to young [ __ ] kev
smith
keeps then i'm gonna hand him a bunch of
product cause i'll take some of that
with me unless it's like the fly
and you can't [ __ ] teleport a rest
that keeps becomes part of me and [ __ ]
and i'm like
or like it's the terminator and nothing
artificial will go it has to be flesh
that's true i like your version better
than brundle keeps right
[Laughter]
rundlecam
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months man you
don't even have to leave your home and
guess what is the pandemic you're not
supposed to leave your home 24 7 care
and support keeps as a network of expert
medical advisors prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality but don't call
them up and be like how do i cure kovid
they don't know that [ __ ] but they could
definitely tell you about [ __ ] hair
as he said low cost ladies and gentlemen
it says everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door discreet
packaging
that way you don't get judged by that
judgy ass [ __ ] mail carrier
it's like no this is just my porn oh
well then sir by all means socks this
must be a fleshlight and you're like it
sure must be
i think i'll keeps it
remember kids prevention's the key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so would you act fast act
[ __ ] fast keep it
keeps it
when it comes to your hair save more
spend less man if you're ready to take
action prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com fat man to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's gay
eps.com
fat man to get your first month free i'm
gonna say it one more [ __ ] time for
the people in the back
k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash fat man ladies and gentlemen we
thank
the good folks at uh keeps for
continuing
to sponsor
uh fat man beyond aka the [ __ ] baldus
show on the internet
it must be man because good lord
everyone else falls away man but like
keeps is just like nah
yeah you know i think we can sell vegan
ramen nope
but hey
we
there must be a few people every week
who are just like you know what
free for the first week why the [ __ ] not
yeah i'm beginning to get a picture of
the demographics of our audience
somebody said that in the last show
they're like [ __ ] like a hair loss
motor pills [ __ ] something else
hair in weird places
[Music]
my mind we're broadcasting to hip 20
year olds but apparently it's just a
bunch of people look like us
come here
that's what the internet is anyway
uh we're going to talk about uh
boba fett which i it took me this long
listening to the theme song to realize
they actually say fat fat fat in the
theme song
say his name in the [ __ ] theme song
before we continue can i just clear
something up for the audience oh yeah
uh mark said that this show was brought
to you by the letter q
i just want to be clear it's actually
brought to you by the letter n for not
brought to you by q it's not a q call
out has show has nothing to do with q is
sponsored by the letter n it was a typo
yes like also literally it's just a
letter you guys and also i wrote up a
card season 2 which is all about q so
read into whatever you choose
but come on
uh i just got a notice from will wilkins
who's like uh banff man's band man if
you will
and uh he said uh let me let me let me
get it right here yeah i don't wanna i
don't wanna get it wrong
he goes you're selling noodles again in
june
so emmy's coming there we go
and i'll be able to review them because
i ate the enemy noodles here i'll review
them right now they're [ __ ] excellent
bro
i'm glad they're coming back um okay
before boba fett before boba fett uh i
saw a [ __ ] movie that i want to
recommend ooh
it was excellent start to [ __ ] finish
never seen the story before i always
appreciate when somebody makes a movie
where i'm like i ain't seen that [ __ ]
before
great acting [ __ ] and it's it's it's
there it's it can only go up because i
saw a very
uh early nascent form of the motion
picture by name splinter
oh
he says my kids i saw mark's movie mark
showed me his movie and it's [ __ ]
good
good in a way where i'm like i've been
doing this for 30 years he tried it once
and i think he
understands the language of cinema
better than i do
um it's good chip when do you what what
is the how do you
how will you let i guess you're gonna
take it to festivals and [ __ ] yeah
that's the hope you know i think that
that the first place it'll go is to the
kickstarter backers like they
automatically get a link to see the
finished product which hopefully knock
on wood will be
may-ish i was hoping for march but i
think i
i want to give a little cushion for all
of the people who are you know going to
come on board and help pull this thing
over the finish line
and then yeah then it's a festival thing
then it's a you know we'll take it to
whomever will program it
um and then try and sell it you know
like festivals would be great but if
like let's say netflix looks at and says
you know what there's maybe a movie in
here
great i know what that movie is i can
100 percent make that happen for you if
you haven't as i watched it that was
definitely like i was like oh this is
this is a splinter of a [ __ ] feature
yeah like there's there's story that
takes the place before the short the
story that takes place after the short
there's a whole rest of that plane that
we can play with and personnel like we
we the the lens on that story is very
narrow um because we
only had but so much to do it in and so
yeah that's the hope so we gotta we
gotta lock the picture
um which i hope to do in the next couple
of weeks and then um bear mccreary who
is going to come aboard and do some
musical work um is going to do his
musical work and then we have to color
time it make sure that it looks as
vibrant and gorgeous as it can
and and add some awesome sound effects
and then i think we're doneish
i think we're done i'm sorry when you
say barry mccreary you always have to do
it like this the great bear mccreary
i'm sorry he's never scored anything for
me before so i wasn't sure the protocols
he's so [ __ ] wonderful his score on
masters of the universe is
better than the writing on masters
universe now i know some people like
that ain't hard she man i'm like all
right all right
get it
i hear you
don't worry about it asked an answer
counselor uh but but the uh his uh you
know i say this is the writer like he
elevated that [ __ ] show with his
score it was so good and i think he just
got
either nominated for or won no nominated
for like some pretty like
hardcore award that wasn't even like an
animated award
a composer's award probably yeah he was
very like oh [ __ ]
yeah
something else i
was involved with made a
[ __ ] oh um
the the
this
oh
remember the
secret stash book i do indeed kevin
smith's secret stash which
thick is a dick could kill you dropped
from my height
that uh they just won an award some sort
of design award oh very cool happy for
them it is a very well designed book and
there was a lot of designing to do
oh speaking of design man chogrin my
friend chogrin designed this this is a
kevin smith
guru sku
um he did one for guillermo del toro
this is what the design looks like
that's right
remember that remember he was at the
show yeah yeah
um
this is what it looks like
now we're on boxing [ __ ]
um
here he's got
this is the readable edition then
there's like a green edition the stoner
edition then there's one that's in black
and white they've got a movie in his one
hand in this hand he's got
a joint that has jay's face in the smoke
[Music]
there's a bull horn in this hand because
you know directing
uh then there's a microphone this hand
podcasting a blunt saber
and uh the script for clerks because you
know it's not a kevin smith uh day
unless he's referenced clerks 20 times
and then the heart thing the buddy
christ thing is bard thing really
[ __ ] dope man we're gonna be selling
these on the website i think they have
them at
sideshow.com as well
i just figured i'd share
with our audience
who might stay who might give a [ __ ]
about that [ __ ] um
yeah so once i i i asked for the
audience because there's a lot of people
in chat who are like when do we get to
see splinter uh but the best cans the
best chance is going to be for them to
see at the festival correct i think so
you know unless again you were a
kickstarter supporter um who who bought
in at the i get a link
level which was oh is that right so
they'll get a link and they could watch
yeah yeah like they 100 did you you used
a lot of them in the cast were they
um yeah there was that there's a handful
of people but there's a
there's a scene where it's like oh [ __ ]
yeah there's a big scene towards the end
um and there was a level of kickstarter
support that got you and a role as an
extra
in the movie and so
all those people like some of them flew
in some of them drove in but they came
from far and wide to come
and sit down and and make pretend with
us and they were the sweetest people
because we put them to work
you know they had rave reviews for you
when we did the show at uh
yeah they were they were all so sweet
they were all so sweet including this
poor woman who
like like almost lacerated her hand
but she was supposed to be punching
something off screen and so they put a
mat for her to punch and she just
[ __ ] went ham on it uh her name is
ivy and uh and it just started to like
tear the flesh from her knuckles and i
look over and i see her like icing her
hands with a bunch of little band-aids
she's like marv from sin city i was like
what happened she's like i did that for
you
i'm sorry
she bled for your damn heart she bled
for my art hey banff man i see we had a
we had an issue
did you delete somebody and chat batman
yeah
was it my fault because i used a letter
no
yeah did mark bring a crowd
it's uh
people yelling about joe rogan
and i we're here to talk about boba fett
not joe rogan
yeah yeah about that if you're gonna
show rancor
show it for the ring
which
we'll get to it in a second but like
i'm a writer
you're a writer
and they introduced that ranker and he
talked about riding it
and i knew this was the last episode so
there should have been no goddamn
spoilers kids
spoilers
jay banff man put spoilers up so we
start spoiling [ __ ] we have a new
feature kids
yeah it's just a sticker that says
spoilers yeah there it is there it is
there we go yeah
shit's about to be spoiled
even knowing all that [ __ ] when the
rancor shows up i was like
i'm easy to trick man
i love that show but we'll get into it
in a second let's talk about something
real quick have you watched pam and
tommy i have not yet no
totally [ __ ] great watch the same
director made i tonya which is a
wonderful watch
uh great flick
uh seth rogen doing some amazing
[ __ ] work man like some dramatic
acting
uh
showing off his chops uh he looks great
and he also he looks like [ __ ]
well it's set in the 90s but he's got
[ __ ] 80s because mullet
but i had a mole in the 90s so i guess
it totally works at one point he was
wearing jorts and i was like holy [ __ ]
don't bite my style
um i was like this is 90s um it's
he's great uh sebastian stan is
wonderful although not as tall as as
tommy lee
but lily james
i think that's her name yeah [ __ ]
astounding
like i i went and showed my wife because
we watched me and jen and i was like do
you know what that girl really looks
like
and i showed her like lily james and
something else with her british self
is crazy the transformation that she
looks like like pam anderson maybe
smaller
you know i'm not like i think pam
anderson always occurred to me as taller
um but yeah oh it's it's nuts but one
interesting thing that they're doing in
the show
that i wanted to see if you'd seen
anybody else doing this you know tough
to tell that story
without nudity right like because at the
epicenter of it as a [ __ ] tape the whole
world knows about and stuff
and uh i remember you know [ __ ]
somebody coming into the comic book
store
neon's back and being like here and
[ __ ] popping it in and all of a
sudden there was this video and you were
like where the [ __ ] did this come from
didn't it was before like you know word
had broken and stuff before it
started showing up online
um and i remember that seeing it like
back in 19 [ __ ] 95 and instantly
going like
why i should just give up i don't have a
quarter of the dick this man has
like it was so intimidating it was like
you know for for whatever
titillation factor of watching you know
people have sex should have been there
all it made me do was reflect negatively
on myself
so i was i was having flashbacks to that
as i was watching pam and tommy
like today i should have there were so
many people that were like oh man wasn't
it hot and i was like
all i i couldn't see past that dude's
gigantic [ __ ] [ __ ]
like it seems unfair that you could be
good at drums and that too like one
thing lord
everyone should get one damn thing
when you give somebody too many things
at any event um
this is what i found
uh [ __ ] like captured my imagination
about the show
they're both apparently like they're
naked they're doing nudity but it's
prosthetics so she has a prosthetic
chest on
and he has a prosthetic dick that they
keep [ __ ] showing at one point it
talks and stuff
um
so
it's crazy because they'll have a scene
where it's like you're looking at naked
people
but they're not naked at all
like this could revolutionize the
industry nobody will ever have to do
real nudity ever again
you could just be like
put on the [ __ ]
the second skin and [ __ ] like that
and and you know we'll probably start
seeing a lot more dicks in movies
because of it
you know i don't i don't think that's
the reason why we don't see lots of
dixon movies
you don't think so
i thought it was i thought it was a
shame thing people like well my dick's
not big enough to put in a motion
picture now it could be thanks to these
[ __ ] skins they're putting on people
why don't they have more dicks and
movies what's that all about um
you know
the patriarchy
like honestly that's 100 it is that
is that right i thought you were joking
around no it's that you know men run
these networks by and large um men had
movie studios by and large
and they're like we don't want to see
naked dudes
we just don't want to we will see all of
the breasts in the world
we will see you know
pubis
on the female
pudendum
but we will never like we don't really
want to do that because suddenly then it
becomes weird and sexual and and quote
unquote disgusting in a way that it
doesn't register when it's female nudity
it you know it slips through an art
house movies like i've seen ewan
mcgregor's dick quite a bit because
there was a stretch in the 90s and 2000s
where he would just drop trowel at lunch
let alone you know when they're making a
movie and so i i don't give a [ __ ] i
look every time and i look hard i pause
and go close
yes i only ever see one dick my whole
life is mine so whenever i see another
one i'm like a dog in the wild when it
sees another dog i'm like
what's that
yeah yeah you know and and hbo has
always been a little bit aggressive
about trying to
to draw some
parallels
numbers wise between the number of dicks
they show versus the number of
everything else
so a show like euphoria or like
righteous gemstones will do full frontal
male nudity
in ways that lots of other shows won't
but i think it is honestly just we're
uncomfortable looking at dicks in ways
that we're not uncomfortable looking at
tits
um and so there's a there's a
fundamental imbalance there
uh damian dupin and chad goes kevin you
know they've been doing prosthetics
since boogie nights man yeah of course
absolutely but
you know
it didn't catch on
i'm saying now what are based on what i
saw you know how like some people
saw the [ __ ] t1 thousand and that
captured their imagination like peter
jackson was like oh i could make [ __ ]
an army of orcs and [ __ ]
i saw that fake dick it captured my
imagination i'm like i'm writing nothing
but [ __ ] with fake dicks in it
everyone's wearing a big dick in my
movie in the future mark
yeah
i mean oh man's here it also like yes in
boogie nights it he like cradles it in
his hand
in this show it moves
yes
there's a shot where he dives slow-mo
onto a bed
and it was in play
it's like the third star of the show
fourth right after seth rogen is that
[ __ ] prosthetic dick voiced by jason
manzoukis
it's i mean look i would still
not do any nude scenes because it would
require you to take your shirt off
unless they can give me like a thin
shirt that i could [ __ ] pull up
like like made of spanx and just squeeze
across you but even then you'd probably
see me bulging and [ __ ] and all the
wrong places but
the the the prosthetic
[ __ ] dick for some reason captured my
imagination where i was like this should
happen more i want more of this in
movies i instantly when boba fett was
done i texted dave klein i was like have
you [ __ ] seen pam and tommy put some
of that [ __ ]
in them star wars pictures man
uh people we've got are telling us to
stop talking about this
uh but i will say watch pam and tommy i
thought i think it's really really well
done and i think seth is i think seth
should get like a nod i'm sorry i mean
not he's acting he's doing a really
great job i thought thanks it's not over
it's only four episodes in i think three
or four easy to catch up
uh all right the moment you've all been
waiting for it kids yes i'm here to talk
about it man it's only been a half hour
40 minutes
that's right
is boba fett ladies and gentlemen the
final episode episode seven weird to end
on a number seven but perhaps lucky
number seven who knows why maybe he's
just like look i'm done
i'm done with the story this is all i
want to do
um i just watched it literally like two
hours ago
uh with jennifer and you know i had to
drag jennifer and my wife jennifer
into
watching boba fett she didn't watch the
mandalorian she watched key moments when
you know i was like you have to watch
anything i cried and was like you have
to watch she watched that moment but
going into boba she was like i don't
know but she'd had such good time
with me on like all the marvel shows
that there was a level of trust built up
where she was like all right man i'll
rock some [ __ ] boba fett
and um she got into it kind of like
right from the start
but we were watching this last episode
and you know
i remember
she was like she was not a big baby yoda
person or grogu
um
she was like i don't know why everyone
likes
that character so much and
after you know even last week
when
grosgu came back you owe me 20 bucks
and uh
absolutely even when grosgu came back
she was like oh i get it i understand
that people like it but she wasn't like
she was
transfixed by luke scott walker she was
like this is [ __ ] nuts i was like
right like isn't this [ __ ] like isn't it
nuts how they can like just bring your
childhood to life and [ __ ] they could
literally make a sequel to return to the
jedi and it's kind of what they did so
this week
with [ __ ] was that yeah you will i'll
take it
i'll buy it you know what that'll buy
one of these man
uh a good old
twenty dollar kevin smith snoochy
boochies jay and silent bob joint in a
weed legal state available uh
look at weed maps you can find us on
weed maps so i'm going to draw grogal
ears on uh andrew jackson
don't that'll negate the money then yeah
no no
i want to spend that [ __ ] you can 100
spend it if you've never gotten like
dollar bills with [ __ ] names
written all over it like you can still
spend that [ __ ] do you can you really i
think so like i when i worked at a
convenience store we were told like
don't take money with writing on it
not not money
it's true
the my wife felt point is my wife fell
in love with grosgu with this episode
spoilers kid spoiler spoiler spoiler
spoilers spoilers deep spoilers lots of
spoilers um when grogu you know puts the
ranker to sleep
i looked over and my wife was crying and
i was like
yes
i was as proud as if i had made the
episode myself
no i was was the guy who's like are you
ready to watch boba fett like i just had
the remote
but you know oh my god
uh
she bought into the magic of uh grogu
big time uh
i loved these last two episodes i i
these last two episodes for me
were like some of the best star wars
we've gotten in a long time and i know
some people are like crapping on the
kids on the bikes and [ __ ] the mods i i
didn't bump into that as hard as
everyone else but in the last two
episodes like which detoured into
mandalorian territory
happily
um you know
some of the greatest [ __ ] star wars
they put [ __ ] luke skywalker
in a scene with ahsoka and had her
[ __ ] reference his dad like twice to
be like i'm a friend of the family and
be like just like your father like ah
and like
they they and they put baby yoda or
grogu into that episode and they brought
back amy sedaris
and and and they like it was [ __ ]
nuts everything but the kitchen sink
i was like this is some of the most
satisfying star wars ever made
like since empire strikes back i love
this [ __ ] i know some people have
problem with it but not me man and like
if you got problems
god bless i just don't
[ __ ] did i love it man i had such a good
ass time watching it i said to my wife
afterwards i was like
some of the best [ __ ] star wars of my
life right i'm not crazy i was just like
that is really [ __ ] great i was like
i said i just want to call those dudes
up and be like you [ __ ] rock
oh my god you rock and then i'd also say
i'd add to that have you seen what
they're doing on pam and tommy with the
prosthetic dicks
work that in
um
magic absolute [ __ ] magic man i love
watching uh
john favreau and dave filoni play with
the toys and robert rodriguez who
directed this last episode my boy david
klein shot like a bunch of them
particularly the last few episodes he
shot a bunch of rogue stuff man
and mandalorian stuff like dave's
playing with the big ass toys making him
look good
uh bam fan you wanted to say something i
was just going to say you were talking
about your gen uh
my gen didn't watch the first
uh four episodes we just watched episode
five six and seven
and when uh ahsoka and the mandalorian
are looking at grogu and luke up on the
hill i looked over at her
and she's bawling and she looks at me
and goes can you imagine if that was
jocelyn up there and it was you and i
down on that hill
like it hurts so much and then when he
goes and crawls curls up with the
mandalorian that's what jocelyn does
with us if like we lie on the floor and
so again she's just
sobbing
so it worked for her i i didn't think
the first four episodes would work but
the last three totally did
that was a beautiful shot too
and also jennifer my jennifer was like
like i heard the gasp or i'm like right
like [ __ ] they're delivering it man like
um it was
like when we when we were watching the
episode in mid episode of the last
episode episode seven
jim was like this is the best [ __ ]
western i've ever seen him like right
like it's every western you've ever seen
but with like you know lasers and [ __ ]
like
it's just so true to the spirit of the
original thing you know they kind of
pick a lane and stick in it and i know
some people [ __ ] about like oh [ __ ]
tattooing again
yeah man like i [ __ ] keep giving me
stories like that i'll [ __ ] watch
keep it all on tattooing and [ __ ]
i would like to go back to hoth i'm just
saying that but
i understand tattooing is easier to
shoot because they got a bunch of desert
out here and stuff and snow is cold and
but you know they're going to get there
you know it's coming
um
i uh yeah unabashedly [ __ ] love this
[ __ ] uh
i i love exactly where they left it
i think it was you mark that said like
when they were building that [ __ ]
ship when amy sedaris and and uh
and the mandalorian what's her name pal
i think it's pell
yeah i don't even know this is like that
in the [ __ ] ship and whatnot and with
the dome you were like if baby yoda
ain't sitting that [ __ ] thing
you know by the middle of [ __ ]
mandalorian season three you called it
man it was just earlier
it's harder to believe but i saw i when
i saw that shot i i [ __ ] went oh
because i and my gem as it goes up and i
was like mark literally said
that that was gonna happen and they
[ __ ] did it
i was delighted about that i was so
happy they brought in
grogu i was so glad they didn't tease it
or make us wait for it there was a
moment where like they were you know in
the in what looked like a rickshaw kind
of thing and
pell is just like mando like i brought
somebody to see you
and
they didn't see each other yet he was
still like under a tarp and i was like
oh man if you made him come all this way
and they're not gonna see each other
until
you know [ __ ] the next season you
better make this work and they didn't
they were just like [ __ ] no we're gonna
let them hug
oh i [ __ ] loved it man is i'm telling
you this is the [ __ ]
that like made me a fan when i was a boy
this is the [ __ ] that made me like make
my parents buy me figures when we were
poor bro we were poor people
and my parents would still like [ __ ]
scrounge up 1.49
once a month so i could get my ass a
[ __ ] star war figure and play
the adventure that i saw until you get
bored of [ __ ] and then you start making
up your own adventure which is that
exactly what [ __ ] john favreau and
dave fallonia and and robert rodriguez
are doing with uh
with boba fett man i
i [ __ ]
absolutely
adore it um and now i'm also like
you could straight up
like you know
i've read a story that mark campbell
didn't even do the voice this time
around yeah it's all synthesized it's
all a computer bank
so like and i know they got a lot of
mark's voice from like what is it bam
fan the uh the radio show the radio
drama from the late 70s the npr you
could do young han solo now you could
probably do young
princess leia better than they did in
rogue one like
you can literally like i will give you
all the money in the world you give me
my [ __ ] childhood back like that and
i know i saw some [ __ ] article after
not this week's episode but last week's
episode not just one but a few articles
that were like
um
star wars is giving their fans
everything they want is that a good
thing and i'm like yes don't [ __ ]
write opinion pieces about how like
[ __ ] fan service sucks like i'm a fan
and i came for some [ __ ] fan service
and they're giving me fan service i
don't even know i wanted and [ __ ] like
there's one episode
when they were building the [ __ ]
ship where you know he's got the pipe
from the [ __ ]
trash compactor come on that's like deep
cuts [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
i love this give these cats all the
money in the world let them keep [ __ ]
making it man like i'll tell you right
now
star wars on tv is an episodic chapter
show
of 45 minutes of pop to an hour of pop
i'm finding far more preferable to like
we got two hours let's get this [ __ ]
done everything's got to happen and [ __ ]
i love the leisurely pace i love that he
takes his [ __ ] time man it plays like
a spaghetti western i don't know if
we're allowed to say that anymore but
[ __ ] man i do i dug the [ __ ] out of it
what about you mark
i uh
here's your chance to win some of the
internet back mark
i i'm not gonna
god damn it wow how could you not love
this episode what about wait what about
the previous episode um i i there
there's parts of that episode that i
like quite a bit you know i think that
again the [ __ ] grogu like reaching
out for mando as the ship has taken off
is wonderful and gorgeous and lucasfilm
was very smart to hire the guy who was
deep faking luke better than they were
doing luke and just let him do luke you
know like boss [ __ ] move like oh
you're you're one up in us come aboard
like come and do that [ __ ] for us smart
um
i think
many of my problems with the show
especially the first three episodes and
then the weird very quick pivot to not
being about boba fett at all would have
been solved and i think you know jc had
mentioned it on some facebook post or
something
that if you just
recontextualize the show as like tales
of the mandalorian
and it's an anthology and every
anthology every episode is about another
character who has come into contact with
the mandalorian and how they all have
come up you know glance against the
pikes right so then you do your episode
about [ __ ] boba fett and the tuscan
raiders you know you do your episode
about fennec you know waking up you know
getting shot and showing up in a mod
parlor and getting an entirely like
metallic midsection you do your episode
about grogu and luke you do your episode
about ahsoka you do you drop in and you
do these like anthology episodes
that are all building towards your your
final confrontation and so you've met
each member of the magnificent seven do
your cobb banff episode cop van
protecting his homestead you know
chasing off loving spice runners and
having a showdown with cad bane like do
all of that stuff
but
it it fundamentally stopped being above
a fetch show and i started to chafe
against me calling like i'm expecting
boba fett and now [ __ ] you boba fett it
is all mandalorian all the time and i
love those episodes
but it like the bait and switch of it
was was making my head feel weird
um and i do you know and i'm curious to
know what jc thinks about this as sort
of a deep star wars fan
the recasting of how luke and ahsoka
feel about jedi traditions
whereas
you know the the big kind of lone wolf
and cub ending of of episode six which
is you have to choose grogu between the
jedi and between your attachments and
when you say lone wolf and cub that's
the scene that they literally did in
lone wolf and cup right totally it's you
know it's it's the elder idol ogami
who's the samurai executioner and his
young son daguro and he offers his son a
choice like i'm going on a path to
revenge but it doesn't have to be your
path if you don't want to so you choose
the sword which will mean that you're
going to ride by my side and get revenge
against the shogun who killed your
mother in our entire life
or the ball and that's choosing
childhood and whichever one you crawl
towards will be the one that that you go
and do
and so that's the choice that luke
always like you can
hey hey don't [ __ ] leave me hanging
there was the kid choosing the wolf and
cub man he chooses the sword
really he don't use the ball he is his
father's son and so i would have
disappointed my old man so much
just globetrotter and that [ __ ] all day
long
um and so how luke feels about
attachment given that his attachment to
his friends his attachment to his father
saves the galaxy saves the rebellion
if he if he followed what yoda and obi
and obi-wan told him to do he never goes
to [ __ ] bespin he never tries to save
his father i sense that there's good in
him and i'm not willing to let it go
that's that guy and this is three years
after that right maybe four
five yeah
five it's nine aby and that was four aby
is the end of jedi right
um and so like how how luke is a
completely different jedi at that point
and has a completely different
perspective on those things in the
absence of anybody telling him something
else
because all of his teachers are dead you
know maybe he's still communing with the
the the force ghosts maybe i guess
but for him to then offer grogu a choice
that's so black and white when he has
found success in the gray
um is weird to me and the same thing
with ahsoka who like walked away from
the jedi order because she didn't
believe in the absolutes
you know only a sith deals in absolutes
and so how she would also say that he
has to choose one or the other or or or
countenance that there needs to be a
choice at all
doesn't feel that like it jives with the
ahsoka that
um that viewers might know and so
that that
choice you're offering grogu didn't feel
it felt hollow to me especially coming
from luke
um
and so like that was my biggest issue
and i'm not sure i needed a sort of 20
minute training sequence for a fight we
never got but
so that's another thing can i give a
mark bernardin
flip the script for mark bernardin here
by all means
so
there's a couple things dave filoni is
making this show dave filoni
uh
basically reframed a lot of ways that
people saw the prequel series by doing
the clone wars
now a lot of people had a problem with
the way luke was
in
uh
the sequel trilogy right why would luke
abandon and they gave you a little 10
second flashback about
kylo ren
or ben solo doing some bad stuff and
you're left to accept that
i think this is dave filoni
building a backstory
to the sequel trilogy to help you if you
watch it all the way straight through
understand and and be more okay with the
choices that luke made in those movies
so you're looking at either one or two
things that's going to happen
you're looking at the fact that
luke doesn't know how to teach jedi
and has fallen back on
the dogmatic teachings of his teachers
and that will ultimately be what leads
to the downfall of his jedi academy in
the events of episodes seven eight and
nine i wouldn't be surprised to see that
what i think we're actually going to see
is the fact that
luke skywalker was given a choice by
yoda on dagobah
go save your friends or stay here and
become a jedi
and he went and saved his friends and it
made him the person he was
and i don't think he forgot that lesson
i think he's giving that lesson to grogu
saying
it
you
as like a learning experience he wants
grogu to take
the armor suit and go and choose the
mandalorian i think he would question
grogu more
if groger was like no i want to stay
here and become the most powerful person
in the galaxy i think that's more of a
red flag to luke than basically
presenting grogu with the same choice he
was asked to make and seeing how he
chooses are you going to go choose your
dad or are you going to sit here with me
luke wants grogu to make that choice
luke wants grogu to go we just haven't
seen
episode 4 of mandalorian season 3
where we are going to learn that luke
wanted grogu yes grogu you made the
right choice
it was once taught that attachment is
forbidden but look at me i still love my
sister leia who's around here and i'm
teaching her and all of this stuff i
don't think that
dave filoni who has made more star wars
than anybody else
in the world
more hours you know if you include uh
even if you're just looking at
mandalorian
uh overlooked that
like critical aspect of
who luke skywalker is where he came from
and where he's going
um i i feel like that's probably a
decent explanation or a decent theory
about it um and you know i i i don't not
have faith in dave filoni although i'll
also say that i'm not a big clone wars
watcher like i'm not that invested in it
but you know it's it
the audience coming to this
the last thing they know about luke
is that those are the choices that he
made
and it's a bit of a dick move for luke
skywalker knowing the right choice to be
like
what do you think
kid
you know who's probably 50 years old and
older than i am but like i know the
thing you should do i'm your teacher why
i would be giving you a false choice
that has a hollow bottom to it it feels
a bit like did you learn nothing from
what you did or are you just being a
dick to be a dick
um i mean
like luke knows luke luke
if luke doesn't believe
that you have to choose you have to make
that choice
then why would he pose the same choice
to to grope you it's supposed to feel
like a frat where it's like listen you
gotta [ __ ] pledge you gotta do the
dumb [ __ ] otherwise you can't be in
because i did the dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] too
i don't think it's that better i think
it's a test to see if grogu stays does
luke really want to train grogu maybe
he's not
maybe his his lust for power he's you
know
you know luke he's too old he's too old
to begin the training right yoda didn't
want to train him
obi-wan says no you have to train him
it's it's that moment it's grogu you
have to make this choice and if you make
the choice to stay and become the most
powerful warrior the galaxy's ever seen
that's the that's a choice
down the dark path that's a choice
that we know ends in in peril from the
history i i think he's testing i think
if he tells grogu go save your dad
that he doesn't actually
find out where grosgu's heart is and
where his
his uh intentions are
i mean that that is assuming
that
anywhere in the text we have a sense
that grogu is going to be the greatest
warrior and the darkest person the world
has ever known like that was that was
the skywalker legacy of you're you're
you're you're playing with fire when you
train the skywalker to do anything
groggies are [ __ ] like whatever
species yoda is like they don't seem to
have a ton of you know intergalactic
despots there were hundreds of jedi if
not thousands
most of which didn't go evil a handful
did sure
but like
i don't know i i
i just feel like there's a way to
connect those dots and i see the desire
to reclaim the sequel trilogy the way
that they've been reclaiming the prequel
trilogy but connecting those emotional
threads in a way
that makes sense for a viewer
just of the movies and of this tv show
to to to logic out a little bit more um
and a fear that he might go like full
[ __ ] darth sidious feels premature
given that there's no evidence of that
at all well it's also he likes to eat
frogs it's also audience manipulation
right the number of posts i've seen
about luke skywalker's a [ __ ] dick
and we're going to live with that until
december or january of next year and
then everybody is going to be like oh i
see what he was doing he's not actually
a dick my childhood here i think it's
audience manipulation like they knew
they knew we'd all be angry with luke
until they tell us not to be angry with
luke and you know jj said it himself
he's like as soon as you put luke
skywalker on screen it's like putting
superman what are you gonna do
well you know manipulate the audience a
little bit make them angry at luke
because they actually now
like grogu more than they like luke
just tell you something man
i came like nine times with you guys
talking about it
it was like being in clerks
you had no punch lines it was all
serious discussion about [ __ ] that i had
never thought about
um so yeah i mean i think that's that's
my general
read on on the sixth episode um in
addition to the it's so weird that
there's one scene of your
title character who doesn't even get a
line but okay that's fine
the finale i i understood it
structurally like you're doing the
magnificent seven right like you're
doing
um you know a handful of of warriors in
that gay cowboys and the original seven
samurai gay samurai standing against an
overwhelming number of bad guys and you
pick a location to fortify and you just
you're [ __ ] going to war that's it um
and so i see that
and i'm here for that like i'm always
here for for a [ __ ] you know doomed
stand against overwhelming odds
um it was a real butch and sundance
moment in the episode where
he said something about like is somebody
out there
and i thought i was if i was like man if
the next line is well for a minute there
i thought we were gonna be in trouble i
was like they're gonna die yeah who are
those guys
who are those guys still the fours out
there no for a minute i thought we were
in trouble yeah i mean but the the thing
that that the seven samurai and the
magnificent seven have
going for it is they get their action
masterpieces and and all that but
the emotional tether that your
seven samurai have to the place they're
defending
why it means something to them for some
people it means money for some people it
means redemption for some people it
means it's my home too
all of that is is is in play when you
tell that kind of story
and here i kept on feeling the absence
of i still don't know why boba fett
likes this town so much i still don't
know why it means anything to him i
still don't know why
taking over for jabba and and being the
daimyo of
espa
why that animates him beyond i want to
open a franchise of assassins i want to
run it the right way
you know like and so emotionally why is
he willing to sacrifice himself for this
place and the show never did the work of
explaining that to me and so by the time
you know we're shooting blasters at
droids with shields for a half an hour
and those blasters are never going to
get through i'm like well why are we
doing this
you know like you have the big showdown
i i'm i will uh
i will um
what's the what's the
shaggy
he's making a point checking i will uh
co-sign this a little bit inasmuch as a
you know
once you shoot the shields and nothing
happens it's like
stop shooting the shield stop shooting
the shield waiting for somebody to shoot
under the shields
like shoot into the ground blow a big
hole in the ground because then
[ __ ] could fall through it or
some sort of [ __ ] but they kept going
right at the shield and i'm like
yeah how do you think it's gonna change
now
like i want those guys to be competent
i want them to have had a plan and boba
routinely refuses to make a plan like
the mods are like well you should you
should hold up here it's like i want to
go to my fortress and i'm like yeah but
this is the town you gotta stay and
protect the town and boba should have
said oh well you know what they'll never
think we'd stay here because this is the
worst place to defend so that's what
we're gonna do so we're gonna put sniper
rifles up on the roof you guys are gonna
get up there you're gonna cover this bug
all of this stuff of it's the [ __ ] 18
right like we got a bunch of bad guys
coming we gotta make a plan b a you go
build something out of that cabbage
cannon and face you go and like get a
cigar whatever it is but we have a plan
because i watch this [ __ ] and i'm like
this is so original you're like oh it's
the a-team
right
you know and right down to the like the
butch and sundance like all right it's
you and me boba it's you and me mando
two armored guys taking on the world and
like it's super cool when they fly on
their jet packs and then they just land
with no cover
just getting shot at
like but if we stand back to back it'll
be different no you're just going to get
shot at
i kept on wanting them to be better at
the job you know and then i wanted like
there's the the big showdown with cad
bane which you kind of knew was coming
i still felt they brought in
the previous episode for the first time
in in live action universe as a
character that came from
animated world another dave palone
character right
um so when he showed up uh banff man
what's the what's this bob skinny bop on
cat band
uh you know the way i see cad bane is
he's kind of like um
he's like the new version of boba fett
he's the guy who doesn't talk a lot he's
like boba fett from the clone wars right
who he's like the cool guy he's like the
cool bounty hunter
um
in that show he's the guy that everybody
wanted to be like
right and so like and i and i dig it i
still didn't i didn't i
i'm not gonna say i disagree with you
but i didn't have that
feeling about cad bane
had a cool ass helmet so mysterious and
[ __ ] cad bane is kind of
it's all on front street
yeah but he's a wife couldn't get over
his [ __ ] teeth she wouldn't stop
talking about it she's like i don't like
his teeth i'm like he's not real
don't [ __ ] get off his dick he's a
[ __ ] bounty hunter who taught boba
fett had a bounty hunt if i remember
correctly isn't that what their history
is like he's the one that
like taught boba fett or
because he says he does the whole like
you know
final lesson or something yeah they had
met oh yes did they did he [ __ ] stab
him to death at the end is he dead no
the gaffy stick yeah that's that's
that's how i read it his little thing
was still blinking though
he had one of these things on his chest
that
darth vader light he was blinking which
i thought indicated he ain't dead yet
and as we saw by the end of the episode
cobb vance isn't dead either he's in the
back to tank yes kids that was cobb
vance in the back back to tank some
people in chat didn't know that i'm like
i didn't know that like i looked at him
like who is that he's [ __ ] tim only
fantastic man
jennifer was just like who is that is
that some new character because i was
like oh [ __ ] and she was like is that
someone new i was like no man it's
[ __ ]
tim fantastic you know and so like i i i
wanted there to be because yes if you
watched kong wars and you know the cat
being backstory
maybe that fat that scene means
something but as a person who's like oh
that guy's cooling seems to be a quick
draw and he just killed cop banth and i
think that's bad
like what does that mean to boba fett
like boba fett doesn't know cop vance
really like he's the dude who's wearing
his armor might not even like it
you know so why is killing this blue
skinned red-eyed guy means something i'm
like well the pikes already said that
they were the ones who killed his tuscan
raider tribe
why not have said they hired cad bain to
kill his tuscan raider
tribe and then your hero and your
villain have emotional stakes
then it's revenge then it's
oh i killed those guys
the the [ __ ] the biker gang with my
fire spray ship for no reason because
they didn't do the thing i felt that
they did it was you the whole time now i
gotta [ __ ] stab you in the face cad
bane because now it's personal
otherwise it's all like academic and and
oddly disassociative and man i kept on
waiting
for the first three episodes of this
show and all of that
tuscan raider backstory to pay off by we
need foot soldiers all right i'm going
to go and get some foot soldiers and i
don't need like 10 dudes from the podum
town get the [ __ ] tuscan raiders man
like there's not just 12 dudes in a
couple of tents
there's an army of them in the desert
you know and like where's the scene
where boba fett goes to the high council
of the tuscans and pleads his case and
has to prove that he's one of them
that here's a character who wears
mandalorian armor but isn't a
mandalorian wears tuscan robes but isn't
really a tuscan who has to tell the the
assorted chieftains of the tuscan
raiders why he needs their help and why
why he's doing what he's doing
and then you have the moment when all
seems lost and then here comes boba
riding a rancor with a thousand [ __ ]
tuscan raiders at his back like that's a
scene like that's drama like that's a
set up in a payoff
and we don't get that and so it just
felt like there was lots of things that
were just
there were sketches of ideas there were
there were structures of drama that
never actually delivered
on anything beyond the surface pleasures
of india i hear laser beams and there's
grogu who shows up in like the weirdest
least dramatic way
as opposed to we got our backs up
against the wall what are we gonna do is
that an x-ray in fighter and then they
[ __ ] start raining fire from an
extreme fighter and then the smoke
clears and there's groggy standing in
the middle of the street holding off a
droid thing and crushing it with the
force like
yeah this dude was training with luke
skywalker he's a badass now and not
cowering in a rickshaw like he broke he
broke a robot and he [ __ ] put a
rancor to sleep what more do you want
he's a baby he's a bit but it's just
like how you could have introduced him
to the scene
is like i don't need him landing with
amy sedaris i don't even need stairs to
be there at all
i love that character i love the
character but like if that's how you're
going to do it didn't need it
like give me bad ass yeah i i honestly
when the x-wing land i was like holy
[ __ ] they're going to do [ __ ] luke
skywalker two weeks in a row
and when it was him i was like
i had totally forgotten about the choice
and and so he made his choice you know
what i thought was weird too it's not
weird but it just caught my ear funny it
was when the mandalorians like you're
wearing the shirt
and i guess it is a shirt but it's like
i don't know is it a shirt
like it seems like it's more it's
[ __ ] you know made of best scar armor
and [ __ ]
but yeah you're wearing that very
expensive shirt
yeah or like you're wearing that
high-end [ __ ] shirt that i had made
for you yeah but um
that the quibble is not a
a mark level quibble of you know
that made me upset with you i was trying
to write a better version of the show no
i didn't understand i didn't understand
the fennec shan bit
where it's like
everybody yeah it's like we know where
the pikes are okay great i'm gonna go
and deal with them
she deals with them after the fight is
over and so i was like why did you have
to leave where we could have used you
sniper lady in the middle of this fight
to go over and kill a bunch of dudes
that have already lost
like and also why isn't boba killing the
bad guys why isn't boba fett doing
anything
because they want him to be an anti-hero
and they don't want his hands getting
dirty and stuff although he killed
well because it's one thing to kill the
guy in a gun fight who's trying to kill
you and then you get the upper hand but
it's another thing if he just drops in
on like hammerhead and [ __ ] blows his
head off and [ __ ] or in this case chokes
him from above i thought that was dope
they never done that in a star wars
movie before where somebody just
strangles a [ __ ] in the air and
you watch his feet stop dangling i was
like man in a minute
a minute a minute of star wars star wars
man a minute yeah but it's like
as much my bar kids as we all know
much lower than marx but i i i didn't
understand at the end of it the boba
fett reclamation project like why does
he have to be a good guy
why can't he just stay a bad guy so he
does a good thing he's a bad guy he's a
criminal he's just not that bad a
criminal anymore now he's like walking
down the street [ __ ] are giving
him fruit like now he's like the [ __ ]
godfathers
so i don't disagree with anything you
said so much you didn't see the cut
scene where he took that fruit and he
cut teeth out and he was like
then he had a massive heart attack and
[ __ ] died
i groggy ran away in the garden with a
[ __ ] bug killer
based on things that we saw in episode
five of the mandalorian episode that the
armorer said i think this entire boba
fett reclamation project
is because
what we will see in the next season is
boba fett riding a mythosaur
to reclaim and take over mandalore
and if you have boba fett
win the dark
mando is going to lose the darksaber to
katie sakoff or moff gideon again or
somebody right
and you will see boba fett win it in
combat he will ride the mythosaur as
spoken in dialogue by the armorer in
episode five and he will become the
ruler of mandalore and you do not buy
him
all of this is making him
a sympathetic benevolent
leader for whatever is going to happen
at the end of season three of
mandalorian would be my bet i'll put 20
bucks on it
that you see that mythosaur
on his arm his sigil he will ride it the
way he rode the rancor and save
mandalore
i just think
none of that precludes him still being a
badass
you know none of that doesn't preclude
him dropping on the pikes and killing a
bunch of [ __ ] who need to kill
him because sometimes that one needs to
get done and like if you decide you want
to be a crime lord who just gets to walk
down the street smiling and waving and
keeping your hands clean because you
have a girl to you know you have a woman
here to to to dirty him up
i don't know i just i i don't understand
why he couldn't still be
[ __ ] cruel and still take the throne
of mandalore and then how much more
interesting is that
where a legit [ __ ] criminal is now
the the king ruler king [ __ ]
of an entire culture who's not
mandalorian
that's kind of interesting
disney well i don't know man
i don't know villains get should get to
be villains not everybody needs to be
redeemed you know and maybe there's a
there's a middle path
that lets you still be
somewhat lawful evil
and like
and so maybe maybe i'm also coming to
this after having watched the first four
episodes of reacher
um which is perfectly happy letting your
main character just shoot people in the
back because they're bad
and you're still sympathetic to that guy
um
but they're just old you just sold the
ticket to
[Laughter]
the shooting people on the backs uh tv
show i'm so therefore it's very much
that like can i punch you in the throat
and then shoot you in the back yes i
will
[Music]
why don't they make them [ __ ] reacher
the title should be
can i can i punch you in the throat
shoot you in the back [ __ ] wouldn't
watch that
um so yeah like i i
ultimately was was disappointed by a
great deal of this season
um
you know i feel some of that as a
framing issue like if you told me it
wasn't going to be about boba fett i
wouldn't have expected it to be about
boba fett
i think some of the ideas were
interesting and some of the the scene
work had some promise but i think as a
as a finale
to a season it was about as bifurcated
and and and blurry as the season itself
was
um
and i think that that ultimately just
comes down to the emotional payload that
you're trying to deliver
and
some of it is just you know i know
people tired of me saying this but it's
math
it's you know it's setups and punch
lines
and if you're going to set up certain
things then there's an expectation on
the audience's part that you're going to
deliver especially when it's in motion i
mean plot is less important but you know
what does this character want what is he
willing to do to get it what gets in the
way
you know once you articulate that
then you can have all of your fun you
know and then you can you can do the
thing where we're wrapping up when you
when you can wrap up a season as well as
season two of mandalorian wrapped up
where
all of those story threads came together
all of the emotion worked all of the the
character stuff and all that action paid
off
and then you can do something as [ __ ]
cool as having to be luke skywalker
and then it's not just the chum of
nostalgia then it's story and story is
what we remember at the end of the day
the reason why we're nostalgic for these
things is because there was a story that
made us so
and when you rely too much on nostalgia
instead of story it becomes hollow and a
little empty which is what hollow means
um
but
then it just becomes ultimately a little
bit lesser than and but if you could
figure out a way to squeeze drama out of
grubby showing up when all is is lost
which is what [ __ ] jedis always do
amazing if you can if you can make the
we're all about to die it's the last
stand and have that feel real great you
know if you can if you can have
boba fett have to plead his case in
front of people he's never met
adopting a culture and then giving them
what they want out of him like all that
is great like have everybody earn what
they get
um
and i just there's there's parts of this
that just kind of skip skip rocks across
the surface of what could have been a
very deep and an emotionally resonant
show
i didn't hate it um it just ultimately
left me wanting
uh
well he launched his rocket so i was
very happy
i don't know what that to tell you i
don't have very
high demands you sound as disappointed
in the show as
tim gildersleeve and chat who said yawn
gen x man boys
why would you come to this show
and state such an obvious thing and then
say yawn it's like well why would you be
here in the first place like yeah of
course it's gen x man boys man
he's here for the pam and tommy dick
talk
what's up i said he's just here for the
pam and tommy dick talk i'll tell you
i'll [ __ ] do another hour on that
[ __ ] prosthetic dick it talks in the
show
which you know technology
it's amazing somebody puppeteering that
[ __ ] dick
you know not as good as the bantha in
[ __ ] uh
boba fett um banff man where do you
stand on the boba of it all
um i i have a lot of the same feelings
as mark but i think not as harshly as
mark has them
meaning like i agree with everything he
says but ultimately i was like
i saw luke skywalker training a little
yoda guy and
rolled some tears when when you know he
got to see
what running with him in the backpack i
was like oh
yeah i mean i don't know
i i wish i
i'm really hoping
that commando season 3
i will forgive the sins of book of boba
fett a little bit more
let me tell you something you you're
both [ __ ] heretics because there are
no sins
you got a goddamn you got seven goddamn
episodes of a quasi-boba fett series man
like [ __ ] oh
i i do have an answer for why it's seven
by the way a lot of people in chat asked
and you guys had asked the
the running time of these shows is kind
of set
and with mando season two you had that
one episode that was like 20 minutes
in there and everybody was kind of like
what gives like episode six of season
two was 20 minutes why did we do that so
what they did is they basically just
took that 20 minutes and rolled it into
one of the other so we didn't get a
20-minute show so that all of our
episodes were between like 40 and 50
minutes attracts that makes sense i'm
okay with that
yeah i i you know make a show as long as
you think a show needs to be
you know like seven episodes nine
episodes ten six don't care just make it
great if you can you know who would love
this [ __ ] show well you know who does
love this [ __ ] show apparently is
leonardo not this show
the [ __ ] mandalorian
is leonardo dicaprio
he's a big fan
yeah we saw that jonah hill story i
think we talked about
where he was just like oh man [ __ ]
he's like uh leo was trying to make me
watch the mandalorian he jonah hill
thought it was stupid or something he's
not
he's not down
yeah rest of us with [ __ ] the
mandalorians he's not down with the
sickness
um but uh
yeah man [ __ ]
yeah and all of that said i will gladly
go back to the desert for kenobi on may
25th
is that what's next or are they doing
cass caspian or whatever the [ __ ]
uh cassidy and endor
i don't think there's a date on andor i
think the next thing we're getting is
obi-wan probably
bad batch season two right around there
too
so obi-wan will be in the next show what
about ahsoka they didn't start that yet
right i don't think ahsoka is 20 20.
you're shooting mandalorian season three
right now right
uh
[Music]
yes maybe
it were i mean we had dave on the show
he was like
yeah i can't tell you what we're
shooting uh but yeah i think it's mando
season three is happening now
kenobi and it's just called kenobi
and star wars kenobi i think
um
bad batch on may 4th according to chat
and then obi-wan on may 25th
when's that elvis movie open anyone know
it's june
elvis was a big star wars fan
upstairs in his room like where nobody
gets to go on the graceland tour
uh they left everything exactly where it
was and he's got some [ __ ] movies and
and books near the you know on his desk
and show his bedside table
and one of them was star wars that i
thought somebody said i was so hoping
you were going to say that in that
bedroom that nobody gets to go it was
all star wars sheets
oh that'd be amazing and the drapes died
i think the same year as star wars right
like he's 77 7 yeah
i want to say he died in like august or
something like that so we got to see it
he got to see star wars and then
honestly there are times at night where
i'm like [ __ ] it's three in the
morning and i wake up
and the thought that elvis did get to
see star wars before he died
lets me go back to sleep
and i sleep like a baby um like my mama
uh june 24th is the elvis movie there
you go you [ __ ] wait man baz lorman
our buddy austin butler
from [ __ ] yoga hosers no yay
he plays elvis that's he's one of them
committed kids he was in uh
uh what was once upon a time in
hollywood he played
tex i think
he's the dude in the you know car at the
end when the chick's like we're going up
there man
um and he's like scary [ __ ] good he
commits to a part so i look forward to
the elvis thing we i would show the
trailer but we'd get thrown off the
internet
yes we would like to we cannot
um we should get uh davey kline back on
the show now that it's all over
mark will keep a civil tongue in his
mouth
something tells me that that's a dave
kev home show
i don't know if he's got like that much
skin in the game like i know he loves
his work but i don't know if he i don't
think he'd be like what
that [ __ ] yellow chance mark
bernard didn't like [ __ ] the show why
i ought to i don't think
you want me to share the same air with
that man i was so happy for him man as i
was watching that [ __ ] i was like you
got to play with the big ass [ __ ]
toys man you got to play with a rancor
like i didn't even get to play with a
ranger like by the time uh return of the
jedi toys came out and [ __ ] i was like
aging out of it i was 13 14 and [ __ ] so
i never got me a ranker and there
there's dave [ __ ] playing with the
ranker playing with baby yoda
[ __ ] playing with luke skywalker and
playing with like [ __ ] rosario who he
shot on clerks too and whatnot yeah
there's another person in that cast in
the second to last episode of the
mandalorian
i had two people in that show who are
also in clerks three
one of them's very obvious the other
nobody knows about
i do um
yeah
yep yep yep yep this show is full of
[ __ ] tidbits for
for like screenrant and comicbook.com
man
thing that's that's legit [ __ ] like
did you know yes did you know
i want to see the list where it's like
screen rants
top or comicbook.coms
top 10 actors that could be in clerks
three that aren't rosario dawson
from mandalore or from book of boba fett
like number one
um it's crazy that that uh
it hasn't gotten out yet not that it's
like a big
like deal it's a big deal to us because
the actor is a wonderful actor but
you know it's
maybe maybe it didn't get out because
nobody gives a [ __ ] about my movies
anymore
chad thinks it's uh chad thinks it's
grogu
how awesome would that be
something
we ain't got that kind of money we ain't
got baby yoda money
nobody got baby out of money as i
watched [ __ ] book of boba fett each
and every episode i was very impressed
by how big they made their world
like you know i love when they show [ __ ]
like this is how people travel on
southwest airlines in star wars
this is how they make the meat in star
wars stuff like that
but like not only do they populate it
with like you know human beings wearing
costumes and [ __ ] but like here are all
the the walrus men here are a bunch of
boss you know here [ __ ] there's a
hammerhead like and they make multiples
of them and they walk around but it's
not like
it looks who you got to give props
usually it's the a.d department that
sets the background
excellent background on these shows
each and every time i'm like i [ __ ]
am immersed in this world man
and they're spending a [ __ ] pretty
penny they're not going like we can only
afford six like they [ __ ] populated
that town
you know they'd probably use maybe
digital who knows because they that's
how they do the banthas they make more
panther by being digital but uh hats off
to the ad department man i i know this
is not a compliment any ad wants to hear
but i've noticed the background all the
time
and i'm very pleased with it so it's not
just the foreground that's interesting
to me it's like the background has been
has been interesting i'm not like mark
who's just like it's book show's called
boca boba fett shouldn't boba fett be in
it i'm like
hey man [ __ ] did you see baby yoda
did you
did you see when when [ __ ]
boba fett dropped his viewfinder
i instantly i was laying on my bed
[ __ ] eating hummus and instantly i
put the hummus spoon down and
because i knew it was coming man first
it's this then he's going to bend over
and [ __ ] fart a missile at you i will
never get over the bend over
it is the weirdest [ __ ] thing
it's like hold on it's so awesome
it's the figure on the back well like
when they first showed us the boba fett
figure he bent at the waist and that's
how it was meant to do so oh i love that
touch
i love it man i i'm [ __ ] anybody i'm
not gonna fight anybody that doesn't or
says i need more
but you know [ __ ] check your needs
man like if you need more than [ __ ]
like boba fett riding a rancor around
[ __ ] tattooing and
stepping on fox and more than luke
skywalker looking like [ __ ] young and
[ __ ] again like come on lower your
bar
do what my wife did when she married me
and just lower your expectations
don't say lower because that insults you
modify your expectations kids there you
go you'll be a lot happier in this life
that's funny like watching watching
digital luke
and and how far worked i mean there's
still work to be done because sometimes
the mouth was a little wonky and
you know like it's great and a vast
improvement over over the mando season 2
stuff
but we are only really like five years
away from them just being able to drop
in
anybody like alive or dead
you know all of the the work marvel did
in de-aging people and now all of the
work that they're doing with oh you know
we have a voice bank like there's no
reason why
[ __ ] john wayne couldn't be han
solo's father if we wanted to see that
because
all the ass like there's 50 years worth
of movies like we have the face we can
we can deep fake it we can synthesize it
you know the the idea that there is no
longer a barrier between like yeah could
princess leia appear on this show 100
she can
now the question is should she
don't know like that because god yes
they should do everything even if they
only do it for a few seconds
i'm i just i know everyone's just like
oh you're just taking the nostalgia drug
and member berries and i'm like yes yes
that's what i want when it comes to star
wars man i want to feel like i did when
i was a kid and like they're they're
making it happen and not just by being
like here's the exact thing from your
childhood like i enjoy this [ __ ] as much
as i enjoyed star wars when i was a kid
and yes
i was a non-discerning child
i didn't have cheerios i toasted oats
and we liked it oh how we loved it
yeah but it's it there does start to be
like
ethical questions
of like yes mark hamill is alive and can
give license for this to happen and has
given approval for all of that to go on
but
carrie fisher has since passed and
cannot give such permission and
approvals
and so no her estate can but then it
becomes an interpretation thing of like
i think my mom would have been okay with
this or i think she would have hated
this and does disney then stop
you know like what's to stop him from
doing it i know that
you know i've heard on relatively good
authority that disney has scanned in
every actor of the mcu
like they've got those assets and a hard
drive somewhere
and if they decide that they want young
robert downey jr to be in something if
they want young tony stark to make an
appearance in a flashback they can do it
they don't necessarily need our dj's
approval for that do you
do you think that that starts getting
written or has already been written into
contracts so like uh i just watched
eternals uh like harry styles when he
signs on to do
eternals
is he now
signing on for a seven picture deal
plus
five pictures where he doesn't he
doesn't physically appear but his
digital likeness does
do you think that starts to become part
of it it wouldn't surprise me at all
with this technology you know again then
then the question starts to be
do you have to recast t'challa
like
is that a thing that you can just
digitally recreate chadwick boseman to
the point where that's just him and it's
just going to be him and that's how
we're going to continue those stories
like
does does chad rick's estate feel okay
about this would the audience feel okay
about this does it get to be like
weird watching a digital version of a
since deceased person
i don't know but it all gets weird and
and morally fraught and it's a sticky
thicket
that i'm not sure anybody wants to
really start walking down i told my kid
i was like look the moment i drop dead
sell every possible version of me
digital version [ __ ] an nft a pog
like don't [ __ ] wait just
a porg even
talking about star wars um so i'd have
no problem with that if somebody wanted
to like even if like i died and [ __ ]
they're like not only do we want to put
silent bob in a movie we want him
sucking dick i'm gonna tell my kid that
can happen too
i have no i'm dead i don't give a [ __ ] i
have no i don't care what they do with
my
dead corpses they want to animate it to
have me
line up [ __ ] a bunch of dudes and
make like a circus seal done and done
man as long as
my kid gets a check
and then presumably her kid as well
and one day i'll be supporting some
[ __ ] i don't know like for example
like i ain't never gonna have as much
money as dr seuss had but like dr
seuss's estate like
is handled by people that have no
relation to dr seuss anymore
because i guess he's all all his
relatives are gone him and his wife
audrey are gone so it's like it's a
bunch of strangers who are like like
we make our decisions for seuss
and you know once you're dead you're
dead man and once you got nobody like
you know
set up to take over and [ __ ] my kid
hates it when i talk about it but i'm
like i did not
spend [ __ ] 30 years building a damn
good brand just to have you let it
[ __ ] you know fall fallow just
because i happen to die i was like you
turn on the t-shirt machine young lady
just like your father would have a brand
is older than you are
exactly
we're trying to get to levi's country
man we're only 30 years in
all right well enough about the man
oh well
truly
mandalorian season 2.5 um
let's talk about news we must have news
right we have some news let's dive into
the news uh we we didn't talk about
peacemaker from last week's episode but
it was great and the new one drops
tonight right right yeah next episode
we'll do peacemaker catch up and stuff
but in the meantime we got some news
mark dug up some news mark tell them the
news
um let's see there were some oscar
nominations that came out you know not a
ton that is
overwhelmingly germane to us but i would
just like to congratulate the good folks
who made spider-man no way home for the
very deserved best picture nomination
that i'm sure it got i didn't read the
nods mark tell me that i'm right you are
not
what the [ __ ] they got 10 slots they
can't give one to the biggest [ __ ]
movie of like the last three years no
man like this is why and they they're
like why won't anyone watch this show
like [ __ ] make a populist choice [ __ ]
man like you got how many slots
throw in spider-man for god's sakes he
let him swing in there
[ __ ] poor kids always getting crapped
on and [ __ ]
show peter parker some [ __ ] love
and i'm not even being facetious with as
many movies as they now nominate for
best picture it used to be what five yep
most of my [ __ ] whole life it was
five